want to train your brain to
automatically reach your goals it starts
with understanding the identity Loop
your brain doesn't care what you say it
cares what you do every tiny action
sends a signal this is who I am start
microscopically small read one page do
one push-up write one sentence these
tiny actions rewire your brain's
identity map making success
automatic but that's just the beginning
your environment is either pushing you
toward your goals or pulling you away
want to eat healthier stop buying junk
food want to exercise more put your
workout clothes by your bed your brain
flows toward what's easiest so make
success the path of least resistance and
here's the game changer Energy
Management your energy is your most
valuable currency not time match your
tasks to your energy Peaks learn when
you're fresh create when you're inspired
and recharge strategically when you
master your energy time takes care of
itself ready to unlock your brain's full
potential watch the full video to learn
how to design your environment manage
your energy and rewire your brain for
automatic success your future self will
thank you